by the time a movie hits your screen
every frame has been examined by dozens
if not hundreds of eyes still
anachronisms and magical color changing
shirts do make their way into films here
are some of our favorites
judging by its 16 screen adaptations
Pride and Prejudice is arguably Jane
Austen's most beloved work it's an
archetypal rom-com about the cross-class
romance between proper Mr Darcy and
fiercely independent Elizabeth Bennett
Kyra Knightley received an Academy Award
nomination for playing Elizabeth in the
2005 Incarnation director Joe Wright set
his take on Pride and Prejudice in 1797.
around the time Austin started working
on the original novel the movie strives
for historical authenticity but fell
short in the Footwear department
Elizabeth is seen traipsing around a
garden in rubber boots or wellingtons as
they're called in the UK but Wellies
weren't a thing in Britain until the
1850s making Elizabeth's boots an
anachronism
former teen journalist Cameron Crowe won
a screenwriting Oscar for his
semi-autobiographical movie Almost
Famous Patrick fugit plays 15 year old
William Miller a precociously talented
music writer hired to review a Black
Sabbath concert backstage he meets the
members of Stillwater the fictional band
he tours with for the rest of the movie
at one point William watches the band
members argue about the design of their
first ever t-shirt gentlemen
your first t-shirts have arrived
then later in the film Stillwater makes
a stop in Kansas where the lead singer
takes William to a house party there's a
fan of the band there wearing a
Stillwater t-shirt and it's not the
design of musicians were discussing
earlier for its first and only shirt
between 1973's American Graffiti 1974
debut of Happy Days and 1978's Greece
the 1970s were full of nostalgia for the
1950s Greece was an absolute Blockbuster
becoming the highest grossing film of
the year but despite all the poodle
skirts malt shops and slicked back hair
it was very much a 70s film and a touch
of the Contemporary showed in some of
the costume choices during a pivotal
dance scene Danny Zuko played by John
Travolta wears some quintessentially
1970s threads that no teenager would or
could have worn in the 1950s namely a
big collared pink dress shirt under a
leisure suit a few moments later at the
climax of Born To Hand Jive Marty
Maraschino played by Dana Manoff slides
across the floor exposing an accessory
warrant to protect the actor which was
not a fashion choice for the character a
knee pad Unforgiven winner of the 1992
Academy Award for best picture is one of
the bleakest westerns ever made it
offers a gritty unsettling look at life
in the West in the 1880s in contrast to
most mid-20th Century westerns with
their clear heroes and villains and Rosy
adventurous spirit in Unforgiven former
criminal William Money played by Clint
Eastwood descends on a tiny Wyoming Town
in search of two violent Cowboys with a
bounty on their heads much to the
Chagrin of anti-vigilante sheriff Little
Bill Daggett Daggett holds his pants up
with a belt threaded through sewn on
belt loops pants with built-in belt
loops were available before the 20th
century but were very rare the Levi
Strauss company didn't begin attaching
belt loops until the 1920s in the late
19th century when Unforgiven is set
Cowboys and other denizens of the
American West were suspenders or else
they wore pants that fit tightly enough
that they stayed put
in The Godfather films Francis Ford
Coppola tells an epic tale about the
corleones a sicilian American Family who
figures large in the organized criminal
underworld of the early to mid 20th
century the first Godfather is set
primarily in the 1940s and filmmakers
paid a lot of attention to authenticity
capturing the look and clothing of World
War II era America but it's not easy to
shoot on the streets and mistakes happen
in one sequence a vintage car pulls up
to a 1940s looking Las Vegas hotel in
the background stand a couple of
onlookers Not actors they're the very
picture of late 60s to early 70s middle
class America down to their bushy
hairstyles
for decades Jackie Chan has dominated
the global box office with his martial
arts based action movies in 2001 Chan
produced and starred in the action
comedy The Accidental Spy and nowhere
does Chan's signature style present more
than a lengthy fight scene in which his
character [__] you in an exercise gear
salesman turned criminal organization
Target fights off one bad guy after
another while completely nude it's
comical how Chan as un attempts to keep
himself covered with whatever random
objects are at hand pinpoint precise
cinematography also helps keep the
nudity PG-13 but the sequence isn't
perfect
accidents do happen
here and there Chan gives the audience a
little bit more of himself than intended
in other words in one way or another The
Accidental Spy accidentally exposes
almost all of Jackie Chan
Dirty Dancing was a massive hit in 1987.
viewers of all ages were Charmed by the
story of a Summer Romance between 17
year old Francis baby Houseman played by
Jennifer Gray and dance instructor
Johnny played by Patrick Swayze Dirty
Dancing reminded older audiences of the
good old days when they took summer
vacations at Catskills Resorts and sex
talk was for science class if that while
keeping things as expressly early 60s as
possible Dirty Dancing filmmakers made a
major misstep when it came to baby's
wardrobe she spends most of the summer
in a pair of very short denim shorts Not
only would those be considered risque
according to early 1960s standards but
they didn't even exist denim shorts like
babies didn't go mainstream until the
much more libertine 70s when they were
popularized by and named after Daisy
Duke a character on The Dukes of Hazzard
the Indiana Jones movies were conceived
as an homage to mid-century film cereals
by franchise creators Steven Spielberg
and George Lucas fictional treasure
hunting archaeologist Indiana Jones is
the hero and in Raiders of the Lost Ark
and Indiana Jones in the Last Crusade
Nazis are the bad guys Last Crusade is
set in 1938 and Indie encounters Nazis
at a book burning
Nazis I hate these guys
the Nazis are clearly identifiable by
their uniforms which are all real they
were sourced in Eastern Europe by the
film's co-costume designer Joanna
Johnston but they aren't completely
faithful to 1938. all the actors
portraying Nazis wear uniforms loaded
with medals awarded for tasks and acts
of War committed during World War II the
thing is that war took place largely in
the 1940s so those medals and the
battles in which they'd be one wouldn't
have happened yet
Braveheart is the true life story of
William Wallace a 13th century Scottish
folk hero and leader of the opposition
against the more powerful and better
equipped English forces while the
characters and story are mostly true
bravehearts still a movie and filmmakers
including Mel Gibson recipient of the
best director and best picture Oscars
for the film took a number of creative
liberties with history Braveheart deals
with Scottish identity and unfortunately
many of the film's inaccuracies relate
to just that for example the most
enduring images from the film are of
Gibson as the warrior Wallace heading
into battle wearing blue face paint
known as woad and a plaid Kilt the thing
is Warriors wore woad about 1 000 years
before Braveheart takes place and real
Scots didn't wear the type of tartan
that Gibson's Wallace wears until 500
years later
today thoroughbred horse racing is a
specialty sport but in the early to mid
1900s it was enormously popular it takes
a big budget high-profile Hollywood
movie like the 2003 Sea Biscuit to
restore Fame and interest to the
Forgotten athletes horses and Riders of
the period Seabiscuit was an unlikely
champion who became a big winner In
Crowd favorite during the Great
Depression Toby Maguire played
seabiscuit's primary jockey John Red
Pollard in the film's mini racing scenes
he's seen wearing a racing helmet with a
prominent chin strap but in the 1930s
jockey's helmets didn't have chin straps
those were introduced into horse racing
until the 1950s about 20 years after the
events depicted in Seabiscuit milosh
Foreman's film adaptation of Peter
Schaefer's play Amadeus tells the story
of the last days of famous composer
Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart and the hatred
in Envy felt by his rival Antonio
salieri in 1985 Amadeus won eight
Academy Awards including best picture
Best Director best actor and best
costume design the head of wardrobe
Theodore pishtech brought the Lush
elaborate world of late 1700s High
Society Vienna to life outfitting the
actors in Exquisite wigs waistcoats lace
Frills and petticoats but pishtech put
zippers on the costumes in a scene
depicting the ballet and Mozart's opera
The Marriage of Figaro Telltale metal
teeth can be seen on the dancer's
outfits I don't understand
is it modern
zippers didn't exist in 18th century
Austria the modern zipper wasn't a thing
until about a hundred years later
La La Land both does and doesn't capture
the vibe of life in modern day Los
Angeles for example there are
surprisingly few spontaneous but
expertly choreographed musical numbers
on the freeway despite the countless
hours Angelina spend stuck in traffic at
one point Sebastian the character played
by Ryan Gosling and Mia played by Emma
Stone have a road rage encounter during
this sequence jazz pianist Sebastian
wears an appropriately retro brown shirt
but in the next scene he arrives at his
apartment to see his sister Laura
wearing a blue shirt despite not having
had the opportunity or time to change
after Laura takes off Sebastian sits
down at the piano and he's once again
dressed in that brown shirt it's not a
magical shirt nor were scenes of
Sebastian furiously switching shirts cut
out it's a continuity air which La La
Land director Damien chazelle
acknowledges in a commentary track on
the DVD version of the film
on the whole Captain America the First
Avenger is a solid piece of
entertainment it elevated star Chris
Evans to super stardom spawned two
sequels and is one of the best loved
Marvel movies in history what we're
saying is it's hard to pick this movie
apart
but in the midst of all the pulpy action
and pleasantly retro vibe that critics
applaud in Captain America there's a
historical slip up we can hardly believe
made it into the film about an hour and
a half in during the train raid scene
Kenneth choi's Jim Morita is shown
wearing a high-tech earpiece what looks
to be a Bowman communication military
headset which definitely didn't exist
during World War II
no